another step up movie step up revolution
now step up revolution is another step
up movie involving a bunch of really
talented dancers who cannot act in the
movie that solely exists to showcase the
dance choreography and dance moves which
are really good by the way which is
symbiotically woven into a movie plot
that's really predictable and cliche now
first of all let's touch on the acting
the acting it's not good at all I mean
everyone in the movie they're all really
good dancers so you know something's
gotta give man the talent has all been
allocated here which means the acting
talents probably not gonna be good and
it's not to the point where you start
seeing other characters and you're like
they seem good but I know if they were
in any other movie with other actors who
actually are actors who act they would
look terrible but because they're up
against these other people who can't act
they're like the better of the bad
actors so they start looking good to you
and you feel like you're just going out
of your mind however the plot if you can
call it that has to do with a bunch of
flash mobs that are competing for
YouTube hits yeah YouTube hits which
almost makes me think that YouTube is
backing this movie which almost makes me
feel like this review is gonna get
pulled from YouTube in three two one so
they're all competing for YouTube hits
and the grand prize is you know money or
some [ __ ] like that I don't know why I
don't remember actually what the main
prize is in the movie pretty sure it's
cash Izone doubt on that one let me tell
you I actually like the overall message
in the movie which is pretty much free
thinkers versus corporate people who
want to lock free thinkers in a box you
know people who are like no you can't
have hopes and dreams you need to go to
college for four years if not for six if
not six eight after that you wear a suit
get a job rinse and repeat for your kids
that's the way it's done there's these
people who are like that doesn't really
fit me if I'm being honest with you guys
not having a boss is really invaluable
if you can find a way to make money and
not have a boss do that another thing
that's cool in this movie is the dance
choreography the dance sequences are so
awesome I get really entertained by that
stuff I love it when it's on but then
when it's done I'm like well it was
awesome but then again there's like
America's Got Talent and YouTube videos
that have a bunch of really sweet dance
sequences and choreography for
professionals and independent people you
can just be entertained right there I
don't know why you would have to pay the
price of a movie
eater ticket in 3d which is more
expensive so I mean really and the
cheesy ass love story is a cheesy ass
love story let me sit closer to the
microphone it's a cheesy ass love story
the chick in this movie though
ridiculously hot like the chicks are hot
the dudes are cooking and of dudes that
other dudes want to look like they're
like I want that dudes abs I don't have
them now but I can do this mmm
eat that dude who can dance better than
me and has better ABS and then in the
end this is gonna be a spoiler alert for
people who give a [ __ ]
you don't have to be like oh dude no
spoiler alert for the really good plot
in this movie but if you are I'm warning
you spoiler alert for the next couple
seconds so like nah fight the man and
then him in the suited man shake hands
were like hey let's work together and
this other guy's like hey I'm a
corporate guy too we want to sponsor you
there's other dudes like where do we
sign up I was like oh sweet so you
fought the man only to be in the pocket
of the other man that makes sense
idiot are you crying he'll probably be a
really wealthy idiot but idiot I want
the money you're gonna get them I will
say if you're a dance fanatic you'll
enjoy the [ __ ] out of this movie but if
you're a person who just wants to see a
good movie step up revolution would be a
good time if you're drunk yeah and now
it's a party buzz the moves
it's your favorite dance movie out there
what is it whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]